what's up reject nations greg al-baqir
and it's John here we're going to murder
some people on the Orient Express today
yeah before we go into this though I
wanted to give a thank you to the
countless people this past week
something just happened where a shitload
of comments came in and a lot of people
are just commenting on my weight loss
you know like whoa a lot of must've lost
a lot of weight suddenly at one point
where everyone started noticing so I
just wanted to say thank you because it
keeps me motivated to go I haven't
reached my full my final goal yet once
every time final goal then I'll post my
sexy before and after photo because
right now it's not a sexy after it's
just like impressive that actually is in
the before and progress yeah this is
like a middle stage I still got a ways
to go but you guys are really helping me
keep motivated and inspiring me to stay
on track with my new health habits and
to keep exercising so really appreciate
you guys noticing cuz you know for a
couple years I've got a lot of fat
comments great to have a lot of weight
loss gums come in now I need from you is
for you guys to tell me how good I would
look if I had muscles so that that way I
will be motivated a yeah this guy's been
weightlifting you know he started off
with 7.5 pounds on bicep curls now he's
at 20 on each side yeah he's getting
stronger one day I will have an
impressive memory flex I like ready to
select legs yours is like that's like
I'm rocket in your group no there's Jon
flicks sir Tyrone magnets and then a
bunch more people as ended yeah tone ah
don't be shy anyway my Rashad Murder on
the Orient Express Agatha Christie right
in that sick murder mystery oh yeah
everyday we doing a page in the dick
shoutout for none other than Garrett
hood today Gary
[Music]
the shredders gonna get a lot more fun
see more fun
[Music]
in modern there is something about that
tangle of strangers pressed together for
days we have nothing in common but they
need to go from one place to another we
shall find never see each other again
hey Mordecai - oh my leg up on Christmas
I see even on this train
a passenger has died
what so I got him after all you last you
more skid no no no not well he was in
perfectly good health he had a gentleman
indeed he was nervous
amazing he is old Roman was lounging
around my cabin in a little tonight
nobody listened to me if there wasn't
murder
what is going on and there was another
act the murderer is with us and every
one of you is a suspect and who are you
how back my name is a cute Powell and
I'm probably the greatest detective in
the world
let's stance out during the trailer huh
Wow the cast all the Academy Award
nominee isn't it need not be zebras late
I didn't recognize her there interesting
who is Johnny Depp supposed to be no
they didn't spend any time on him is he
the one that's why the IMDB is here
ratchet maybe we should read the book
and Clank in something it's a very long
book they might have a hard time sitting
through okay I read some Agatha Christie
in high school it wasn't too thick I
really liked the trailer
speaking of exercising one of my go-to
songs lately is the song believer by
imagine dragons what the hell do you
want is true we gotta hit the Millennial
to open and I wasn't doing is just
telling a movie so did not fit
whatsoever yeah what kind of boots long
doesn't even match at honor the lyrics
this is Brandon oh you did this yeah be
aware that if something doesn't feel
right
yeah I know imagine dragons are in like
trailers now their songs aren't a lot of
trailers these days I guess hi I just
don't I feel like with a bunny favelas
of setting margins I'll trigger I feel
like there's gonna be some kind of
sci-fi action movie that's going to end
up with like a really classical music
track because somebody just fell asleep
and mixed them up yeah yeah something
that should have gotten believers is
going to be without it I've seen a few
of Kent Brian assumes he's directed yeah
started like wah wah West classic
performing love what you are man yelled
at all seven climb in minority know
kenneth branagh the villain Oh easily is
he's lovely
yeah that made you notice
mine plays President Grant and the guy
out of his gourd alarm is Gordon it was
yeah I've seen a few of its elves I've
seen the Frankenstein movie he did
Frankenstein you son of a [ __ ]
you know of course like Thor I've seen
some in jack ryan shadow recruit whoo
and I have seen some Cinderella as well
he does films that are done I'm some
pretty good films and I really liked the
work Cinderella her is really good this
one though from looking at images of the
trailer seems like he gets to hone in
more on a Kenneth Branagh style that he
might actually have because he's done
like 20 films or something so this might
be a defining and it might actually have
a defining style with this film because
that shot I really love that tracking
showers going around you're seeing the
whole yeah the suspects that was a
really really cool shot and I don't
really I don't think I don't think the
moogle itself will have like the text
appear and insane who they are those
that Owen treat that title gag is it is
like a trailer state yeah be like yeah
I'm with you on that I definitely am
excited to see what he does with this
because kind of Kenneth Branagh my
experience in his directing is more on
the Shakespeare side it's like as
someone you do and I saw Hamlin I'm glad
yeah I know he seems to like to stay in
the literary environment you know most
of his things are based on texts of some
kind you don't have a like this stage
context of Shakespeare so I feel like he
can just kind of frame it how he wants
do it later or was it I thought a good
example of like cool shots and yeah so
this seems like you definitely get a
dial back on the thrills but it's going
to up the tension and I'm excited to see
him do a murder mystery yeah that's I
feel like there might be more freedom of
style here that he has access to whereas
you know Thor you still are under the
guidelines of the MCU all the people you
know the head of MCU and then you have
Cinderella which is fall the cartoon
there's an original film by silly LeMay
and then that was based on a book so
this would be another adaptation of that
same source material regardless though
it seems like there's a much more
specific style he has here I like the
production design the costumes look
great I like them to take place in this
era to begin with and I'm excited to see
I feel like Johnny Depp this
it could be a role where he because
giant devon has become kind of a new
janeiro for me where every once in a
while during this committing you're
doing a great job a lot of that wasn't
to know every Monday and I feel like I
mean what a huge cast like this I'm
hoping he brings his a-game because I
expect nothing less of the rest of the
actors to bring their a-game such when
Kenneth Branagh is an actor's director
he is himself a wonderful actor so I'm
hoping he can still bring a great
performance out of Johnny Depp to try
that's clearly he's the one I'm most
worried about the air because this is a
tremendous ensemble and and I hope that
he's the kind of actor who at least
bring the a game when everybody else
who's read a game you know Johnny
deficit is an odd duck to me and I'm
kind of worried about him now because
you know just seems like he's struggling
well there's a couple of people here
that he's worked with before Michelle
Pfeiffer a worm in Dark Shadows Penelope
Cruz on Stranger Tides doesn't mean you
can do a great job none of those movies
did you come in yet the cool thing is
though with a huge cast like this the
thing that I can get most excited for
are scenes of dialogue and it's gonna
have plenty of that because you know
whenever I heard Kenneth Branagh doing
like jack ryan shadow recruit even Thor
and then Thor I liked a lot that's like
a champ Ron I want to see I want to see
him do a movie words you know characters
interacting with each other cuz he's an
actor's director my inner for the action
when it comes to a Kenneth Branagh oh
yeah totally
wellness and that's where the
Shakespeare stuff to meet bland exactly
whole business because he does a great
job with those and also he's proven he
is more than capable of having an
assured hand at direction while also
being on-screen yeah oh yeah yeah and
he's also a guy who I think can shoot
something that's this is based on a book
not necessarily a play but you know
still shoot something that's contained
and this dialogue heavy but that won't
just feel like oh you just you just plop
the camera in the middle of a plane yeah
you know like I feel like he will bring
you know a cinematic style but yeah I'm
hoping everyone gets a good amount of
equal screen time and especially the big
players that we all know I mean
giant dad Michelle Pfeiffer Penelope
Cruz Daisy Ridley Josh GAD will in the
boat kenneth branagh self
judi dench a lot of other actors so i'm
not familiar with but today we put a
huge actor list I'm hoping a lot of them
get a lot of interplay throughout the
film
it's an exciting ensemble and these are
all people like I'm excited to see them
all just for their characters but also
how they interact with each other where
the mystery goes because I'm not very
familiar with the course of this story
just having the man himself play Faro I
mean that's that's yeah he's a guy who
can fill those shoes because that's a
beloved character you know I haven't
seen some of the Mays version obviously
over the book so I'm wondering though
for it being a murder mystery is this
one going to change anything from the
source material like to who the murderer
is is it going to or from Sidney Lemay's
version because the mystery has been out
there for so for so many years now will
it upset fans if you if you can change
it all
spoiler but I'm thinking like this is
another adaptation you can't just give
it the same plot turn the same reveals
now I feel like you have to mix it up
and make it a little bit more of your
own it's something that I think would
have to kind of sear away a little more
from its source materials and the novel
isn't out there for ages and some of the
majors I don't know if that's completely
accurate to the book I imagine the main
plot points and the reveals are see
that's something I'm very much wondering
about actually I'm interested to know
how they decided that this now is the
time to go back and revisit Agatha
Christie again yeah it's not something
that the young people are SuperDuper
familiar with or we got but we revised
and Dragons anniversary I have to
imagine that that's probably what
happened yeah we're going who is what is
the Poirot what is why do I care about
this train yes probably the biggest
thing I'm wondering because I can see
why they wouldn't change it because it's
not just a common name that everyone
knows anymore but at the same time they
do that yeah you change things around
and if we are doing this for a second
time on the big screen I do kind of
agree it yeah you'll have to change it
at least somewhat so that it's not just
a psycho remake we have a book
adaptation yeah yeah I agree
or just with a shinier coat on yeah
I mean it was colorful the production
looks great and the cat gets me excited
so I don't have faith in it and then the
set of the score by imagine dragons and
I hope they use it throughout of it I
hope they score the entire movie yeah
actually get 20 originals Nagas just
position Millennials that's what I'm
counting on that
it's holiday season we got to get the
families on board I think the only other
thing this trailer needed was from the
director of sword and Cinderella all
right well thanks for recommending that
trailer our way you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram and patron of the day shout
out before I go into this now big thank
you to everyone who has been
contributing to our patreon doing a lot
of exclusive perks on there a lot of
funds loose of videos to print a lot of
red and medieval quick gardening vlogs
no worries we sing in a rock band like
whose religion war ended stuff on there
but it's been a blast and I'm loving
interacting with the community we both
walk back to our shout out Gareth Gareth
hood Gareth said I don't want to reveal
the exact number he's contributed
because I don't want to make anyone
jelly about the guy boy he has
contributed way more we could have ever
asked for
he is the good and I know we make our
shoutouts a little more sarcastic but I
want to make a sincere shout out to this
man I mean he's from London but he's
like living in the Middle East right now
and when we did a Google hangout he
chimed did like four o'clock in the
morning just to talk with us this guy's
a dedicated father a hard worker
businessman and he's also a nerd I
really enjoyed talking with the yeah I'm
the cool guy and in all sincerity like
to it is like they're all really cool
everyone is and none of you suck
none of you suck especially Garrett
could especially do who I love his beard
and I you know in all sincerity Garrett
I would love to try some anal pleasure
with you no jokes this is a sincere
shout out go inside your hood
you know what I mean I mean if you must
know what I mean if I brought up what it
was brighter um I tried to pick that one
up I got caught you know you hooded it
there there our anatomical parts
referred to as that I just don't think
Jen's have one oh um I see what you're
going to lead YouTube censors they'll
stay to the end of the video it's there
whatever it's watch made mentoree Fox's
videos online
oh yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter thank you long